so they're telling us that r fifths is
equal to eight tenths and we need to
figure out what is r going to be equal
to and they help us out with this number
line where they've put eight tenths on
the number line and that makes sense
because to go from zero to one they've
split it into one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten equal jumps and
at this point we have gone eight of
those ten equal jumps between zero and
one so that is eight tenths and they've
also labeled one-fifth for us and one
way to think about it is
if we go if we look at these bold lines
zero
one
two
three four
five if you just look at the purple we
have five equal jumps so each of those
jumps are a fifth and so it makes sense
that our first jump right over here gets
us to one fifth and you can see that
that is equivalent to two of the tenths
i'll just write that up here for so we
can see that equivalence one-fifth is
equal to two-tenths but how many fifths
is equal to eight tenths
pause this video and try to figure it
out
all right well
this is one-fifth if we do one more jump
of a fifth that would be two-fifths then
if we go another fifth that will get us
to three-fifths and then if we go
another fifth that will get us to four
fifths which we see is exactly
equivalent to eight tenths and that
makes sense because we also saw that
every fifth is equivalent to two-tenths
so four-fifths is going to be equivalent
to eight of those tenths we see that
very clearly right over here and so r is
equal to four
four-fifths is equal to eight-tenths so
r is equal to four let's do another
example
what fraction is equivalent to point a
so pause this video and see if you can
figure that out
all right so let's figure out where
point a is
so to go from 0 to 1 we have 1 2
3
four five six equal jumps so each of
these jumps are a sixth so going from
zero one jump will get us to one sixth
then two sixths then three sixths then
four sixths then 5 6
and so can we see 4 6 in the choices
no i do not see 4 6 so we have to find
an equivalent fraction to 4 6. so we
could go choice by choice the first
choice has 5 6 well we very clearly see
that 5 6 would be here on the number
line which is clearly a different place
than 4 6 so we could rule out this first
choice but what about these other ones
let's see let's see how we can think
about it four-fifths versus
four-sixths
could those be equivalent if i have four
out of five versus four out of six
that's not feeling too good so i'm gonna
i'm gonna put like a a curly line to it
that's not feeling right that if i could
have four out of five equal jumps or
five equal sections that that would be
the same as four out of six equal
sections if i divide it into six equal
sections each of those sections are
going to be a little bit smaller than if
i divide it into five equal sections so
if i have four of each they're going to
be a different value actually when i
talk it out like that i feel even more
confident that i could rule this one out
now what about six fourths
well one way to think about is four
fourths would be equal to one so six
fourths is going to be beyond one so
it's definitely not going to be where a
is so i could rule that one out
and we could say oh well maybe it's just
going to be d but let's make sure that
this makes sense two thirds what does
two-thirds look like
well let me try to divide this this part
of the number line from zero to one into
thirds into three equal sections
so i have zero there
and then that could be one-third
two-thirds and then three-thirds that
looks like three equal sections so this
is one-third
this is two-thirds i'm making another
jump of a third and then when i get to
one of course that is three-thirds and
or we could have said 6 6.
and so point a which is right over here
i'm writing over it that is indeed equal
to two thirds you can see each jump of a
third is equal to 2 6. so it makes sense
that 4 6 is equal to two-thirds or that
two-thirds is equal to four-sixths so i
like this one